Prof: Last time we
looked at the cantos of the sun,
which is the canto of
arithmetic and so--
;and we discussed actually the
variety of philosophical
strengths,
theological and philosophical
ideas that compose Dante's
circle of knowledge,
this encyclopedic compass or
what's worth knowing.
Today, we move into the Heaven
of Mars, which is as you know,
the god of war,
the name of the planet,
and it's the heaven of music.
Dante links Mars and music
because harmony,
out of the belief that harmony
is the meeting point or the
result of discordant elements,
a kind of concordia,
a concord,
an attuning of hearts reached
through discordant elements.
The discordant elements can be
different sounds;
it can be the passions within
us that need tempering and so
on.
This canto is--can be read
prophetably and you can do some
of this on your own in
conjunction --
I will allude to it in passing
-- in conjunction with canto,
for instance,
XV of Hell;
within XV, XVI,
and XVII of Paradise.
You could read it;
XV was the encounter with
Dante's own ancestor
Cacciaguida,
and so inevitably the reference
to Brunetto Lantini literally
imposes itself on us,
it compels us,
we are compelled to draw
parallels and see differences
between the two ancestors who
claim,
make different claims on this
descendant --
intellectual and dynastic
descendant -- who is Dante
himself.
You could also look at it from
other, many other points of
view.
The point of view,
for instance,
of the other references to war
and the kind of the clashing
sounds throughout Inferno
that Dante produces.
If I were to give a title to my
remarks today,
which I really don't because I
think it's the variety of
suggestions coming from a canto
takes over the desire to be too
schematic and thematic,
but if I were to give a title
today I think it's really very
encompassing,
I would call it "Self and
History."
These seem to the most--the
strongest questions that Dante
raises.
They're not--the terms,
the question self and history--
the relationship between the
two may be new to us here,
but we certainly have been
talking about history before.
The last time we did was in the
discussion of Canto VI of
Paradise,
where Dante gives -- in the
Heaven of Mercury --
Dante gives this overall
history of Rome,
its humble beginnings and then
the deconstruction of the empire
and the crisis of the empire.
So that's really one thing that
you know.
The issue of self in itself is
something we have been
discussing ever since we started
the Vita nuova,
with the idea of a lyrical
self, of a self who removes
himself,
as you recall.
That's what we mean by a
lyrical self,
removes oneself from the world
of history,
the contingencies of time,
the viscous realities of the
city,
and takes shelter in the
chamber of his imagination in
the world of his ideas,
his dreams, and memories,
and there he constructs his own
self.
That was the point of the
Vita nuova.
When we began reading the
Divine Comedy I insisted
on the autobiographical focus
with which at least the
Divine Comedy begins.
This is his story,
this is his unique experience,
the pilgrim's own--Dante's own
unique experience and that seems
to have come to an end with
Purgatorio XXX when
finally the novel of the self is
sealed.
As you remember,
with the mentioning of the name
Dante,
then a new phase begins in
Dante's construction,
which is more educational,
more speculative,
which is really the world of
Paradise.
But so, we talk about self and
history in a way that maybe
Dante's never quite coupled the
two terms before;
he does so in Canto XV,
XVI, and XVII of
Paradise.
This is really the double focus
around which everything moves.
Let me give you--I will give
you a reading of the various
details,
but let me give you an idea of
what I have in mind first of all
and the way of thinking about
this issue.
I want to draw your attention
to the presence of some mythic,
mythological figures that
Dante--whom Dante is evoking and
they are very different among
themselves,
but they're all--it's a way of
reflecting on Dante's own idea
of selfhood,
Dante's own relationship to an
ancestor,
his own private history,
who in turn has had a very
complex and for Dante nobling
relationship to history.
He is a crusader;
he fought in the Second Crusade
of 1149 under the Emperor
Conrad;
he is proud of this belonging
to the crusader,
to fight as a crusader.
A version of the relationship
one has or thinks one has with
history, both Cacciaguida's and
Dante's own relationship to his
grandfather.
Let me tell you first of all
these mythic figures and then
we'll talk about them.
Dante is--beginning with Canto
XV I will just remark in
passing, I will not--I will
leave it to you do more
diligently than we could do it
here.
The presence of musical
metaphors, which is not
surprising,
in the Heaven of the Music,
"Gracious will,
into which--"
this is the beginning of Canto
XV,
"Rightly-breathing love,
always resolves itself,
as does cupidity into an
ill-will,
imposed silence on that sweet
lyre."
This is the--The soul becomes a
kind of musical instrument,
the sweet lyre and stilled the
sacred strings which the right
hand of heaven tightens and
relaxes and so on."
Then this, "And the
gem," at one point,
this is line 20,
"And the gem did not leave
its ribbon,
but ran across by the radial
strip and seemed fire behind
alabaster.
With such affection did
Anchises' shade reached out,
if we may trust our greatest
muse, when in Elysium he knew
his son,"
and then in Latin,
a quotation,
"O sanguis meus,
o superinfusa gratia Dei,
sicut tibi cui bis unquam coeli
janua reclusa?"
To whom has this privilege ever
been given of having the gates
of heaven open to him twice,
"the light spoke
thus."
So this is the first mythical
reference.
We are really--we could just
say, well Dante of course at the
very beginning of Inferno
makes a reference to Paul and
Aeneas disavowing any strict
connection with them.
You remember when he resists
the call to this huge risky
enterprise of going through hell
that comes to him from Virgil.
He says, I'm not Aeneas,
I'm not Paul,
why should I do what you are
calling me to perform and Aeneas
is the one who had visited Hades
to meet the shade of his father,
Anchises, now recalled here,
and of course Paul is the who
had been taken wrapped to the
third heaven,
meaning a third mode of vision
that allowed him to--
and kept quiet about it,
to see God face to face.
Anchises, the encounter between
Anchises and Aeneas here,
stands for a sort of
relationship of Aeneas that
Aeneas has with history.
Aeneas goes to Hades in order
to find out what the purposes
are for his journeying from Troy
toward an unknown land and he
discovers--
it's a way of Anchises
discovers that he--
from his own father the
presage, the prophetic if you
wish announcement of what it is
for him to be part of history.
Somehow a definition of self,
that's what you find with
Anchises and the Aeneid,
can be understood as that.
The sense that one--how does
one belong in history?
One belongs in history as part
of a providential pattern as the
idea that this was a destined
empire that he,
Anchises, has to found,
and a new history would start,
so that he confirms his
attachment to the dead father
and yet he starts now as the
point of beginning for a new
history.
This is one way of
understanding an epic,
the epic account,
a myth of one's own self
belonging in the world of
history.
This is mythical.
We move on, and it's really a
big--sort of a reversal of this.
I will come back into Canto XVI;
Dante gives a chronicle of the
City of Florence.
That is to say,
first of all,
he's making problematical to us
the idea of where are we to
understand this as self?
This is--it's not clear what we
are to understand as a self.
In the Vita nuova the
self is this nexus of memories,
fantasies, and a will to write
poetry.
In that sense the text
constitutes oneself,
into a self.
I am myself;
I'm the author of this text.
This becomes a point of
reference and this is what I am.
The image and poetry that I
give of myself gives you an idea
of who I am.
It doubles me,
it perpetuates me,
it's a poetic version of self,
but we don't know yet what are
we to take as a self.
Anchises has a different
understanding of himself.
I am who I am only because I
belong to a larger pattern of
history.
This larger pattern of history
is going to be me as a founder,
a founder of a new way of
looking at the world,
the founder of Rome and he gets
the message from his own father.
In Canto XVI,
and I will not go into this as
I'm pursuing the theme of the
mythic references,
Dante goes on really thinking
about writing a chronicle as I
will say in the City of
Florence.
One, Florence is famous for its
chroniclers,
the beginning of the Middle
Ages, and so is history then the
other problematical notion to be
understood as the loco,
events, or is to be understood
the way Anchises understands it,
as a myth that somehow has a
sort of paradigmatic value and
which can regulate and also
arrange.
We can go on arranging our
lives according to the demands
of that myth.
Dante will not answer this
question directly here,
but he does talk about all the
Florentine families and talks
about them in an elegiac manner.
That is to say they're all
decayed,
they're all finished and
extinct, so whatever value this
history may have it's an elegiac
commemoration of the past.
Cacciaguida,
by the way, is very elated at
the idea that the son,
the grandson,
the descendant wants to find
out about the past.
We move then into Canto XVII,
where I think we find something
about this whole issue about
history and the self.
It begins in a peculiar manner,
look at the beginning of Canto
XVII,
the reference is really--it's a
long periphrastic construction,
a long turn of phrase to--for
the pilgrim to describe himself
in terms of Phaeton,
the famous figure as you know,
from the classical myth who
challenges Apollo.
We saw him in the corresponding
Canto XVII of Inferno.
There was an illusion there to
Phaeton so a little touch of the
symmetry of cantos but that's
really secondary at this point.
Look at what the scripture is,
"Like him who came to
Clemente, to be reassured about
that which he had against
himself."
The Disowning,
first of all,
is the story of the uncertainty
of Phaeton's descendents,
that his father was Apollo,
so he reassured himself,
"Him who still makes
fathers weary with their
sons."
This is in the Canto of
Cacciaguida.
What is the real relationship?
That's what that is asking.
That I have to this noble
heroic figure of whom I'm proud,
but what is the actual
relationship that joins me to
them?
"Such was I and such I was
perceived to be both by Beatrice
and by the holy lamb that had
changed its place for me
before."
He's happy that--he seems to
reaffirm this genealogical line
so history now becomes no longer
a chronicle, becomes now a
genealogy.
Can we establish some
certainties that we belong into
a genealogical line?
Can that really account for us
and for who we are?
This is the issue that Dante's
raising.
The figure of Phaeton is a
tragic figure because it
introduces the possibility of,
and Dante says this,
that's what makes fathers weary
of their sons all the time.
The idea that the son wants to
outdo the father,
wants to go beyond the father,
and the idea of tragic
transgression that it can exist
and therefore breach that line
of continuity between--
inter generations,
across the generations.
That's one of the myths.
The other one is much more
tragic than before.
Canto XVII, as you know,
goes on discussing among other
things the--let me read the
passage.
I think Dante says it much more
sparingly,
that is to say without--to my
despair--
he says it much better than
anybody else can,
"Contingency,"
this is line 36,
"Contingency,
which does not extend beyond
the volume of your material
world is all depicted in Eternal
Vision."
This is another way,
still another way of
understanding history.
That there is a contingency
that the world of contingency
can be subsumed within a larger
transcendent paradigm,
that seems to be the order of
necessity.
The contingent world is linked
to the volume where all things
are present in the eternal
vision.
Yet, that's not man's derive
necessity anymore than does a
ship that dropped--
is there some autonomy to
contingency or things determined
by the order of necessity
downstream from the icing which
is mirrored.
"From thence as sweet
harmony,"
last time I mentioned it
musical language,
musical lexicon abounds here,
"comes from an organ to
the ear,
comes to my sight the time that
is in store for thee."
I enjoy very much the implicit
connection between time and
music.
Music becoming the metaphor
that makes audible time itself.
Time is constitutive of music
of course but it really makes
it--
it's an acoustic translation of
the silent arrow of time and now
this is the other,
the third mythological
reference, Anchises,
the tragic of Anchises who
recognizes himself in the
history and in the break,
in the continuity with his
father and in the break with
Troy from his father,
from Troy and the beginning of
a new,
let's say, history.
Phaeton, who turns against his
father and burns the heavens in
doing so, that is the famous
metamorphosis of the origin of
the Milky Way.
As you know,
the Milky Way was understood as
the scorched heavens,
a cosmological disaster that
was happening on account of the
rivalry between father and son,
and now the third is
Hippolytus, Hippolytus,
the Ephedra,
the story of Ephedra and I have
to tell you.
"As Hippolytus was driven
from Athens on account of his
cruel and perfidious stepmother,
so must thou be driven from
Florence."
This is Cacciaguida who
announces the exile as the
fatality that is hovering over
Dante and for which he has to
prepare himself and exile--
you see what it implies also a
sort of necessary detachment
from one's family,
one's country,
one's whole--all the possible
lines that tend to join us and
limit us too.
Dante is not quite Anchises,
he's not out to establish an
empire,
he's not like the Phaeton,
he does not want to overdo,
at least literally the father,
and now let's see who is
Hippolytus,
"As Hippolytus was driven
from Athens on account of his
cruel and perfidious
stepmother,"
Phaedra,
"so must thou be driven
from Florence.
This is determined,
nay is already contrived,"
look at the difference between
determine and contrived,
and the conjunction between the
order of eternal,
the eternal destinies and the
contrivance,
the order of contingency,
the maneuvers,
infernal maneuvers against the
pilgrim,
"and will soon be
accomplished by him who
meditates it in the place where
Christ is bought and sold all
day.
The blame, in the common cry,
shall follow the injured side,
as always, but the vengeance
shall be testimony to the truth
that dispenses it.
Thou," that's the
announcement of the exile,
"Thou shalt leave
everything loved most dearly,
and this is the shaft which the
bow of exile shoots first.
Thou shalt prove how salt is
the taste of another man's bread
and how hard is the way up and
down another man's salary--
another man's stairs."
Excuse me.
Here there is a terrible
mistake that Sinclair makes
because Dante is very careful,
line 60 he writes,
lo scendere e 'l salir per
l'altrui scale,
which means going down and up
and your translator--
my translator here has it the
other way around because he's
following a logic which is--
we'll call it naturalistic
logic.
You go to the palace of the
duke, you go up,
you climb the stairs,
and then you come down after
you have been begging for some
charity and then you have taken
your morsel of bread,
then you can go down.
But that's not what Dante says.
He says you first go down and
then you go up,
and I hesitate to gloss it for
you because I think it's a
little bit clear the kind of
thing he means that for him to
go up is really a descent,
was lowering himself.
It's a little bit of--it would
seem to be a descent into
pride--
into humility but at the same
time because he's reversing the
natural order,
the ordinary order of the
action;
it's really an ascent into
pride.
For me to go up here is--it's
like going down and I'm really
degrading myself.
It's a very interesting line,
acknowledgement of a sense of
gratitude,
a sense of the spiritual ascent
being inevitably at first a
descent into the self,
and then becoming an ascent.
It's really--turns the whole
thing around,
was up and down,
another man's stairs and
"that which shall weigh
heaviest on thy shoulder is the
wicked and senseless company
with which thou shall fall into
that valley,
which shall become wholly
ungrateful,
quite mad and furious against
thee."
The story of Hippolytus is the
story of the stepmother,
to go back to this idea of
self, is the story of a
stepmother who is trying to
seduce Hippolytus;
she's married to Theseus,
and he runs away.
The family becoming the
destructive--the form of the
destructive desires within that
family forces him to go away,
run away and dies.
You wonder why Dante is taking
on and thinking of this tragic
figure to compare himself too as
an exile,
he had this potentially
destructive and tragic
consequences that are happening
to Hippolytus,
and at any rate,
we have three great images by
which Dante is thinking about
what is the self and how is the
self to be determined.
How does the self enter the
world of history?
What examples did he give?
Can we talk about any of the
examples in the past?
I think that this is really the
extraordinary--
the burden actually of a text
that I have been talking about
in the past and it's the
Confessions of St.
Augustine.
That text is about the question
of how the self is related to
history and Dante disagrees with
Augustine.
For Augustine,
the self is one that takes
refuge in the interiority of
oneself and goes on.
At the time of the conversion
he can now rejoin history and
that is thought--to Dante
clearly, a way of entering
history.
The other motif that you can
have is the motif of the--
the other model you have is the
model of Cacciaguida who goes
onto a self-sacrifice of himself
for the benefit of a larger
cause.
The cause of the Christian
crusade in Jerusalem;
then there is the Aeneid
that represents the idea of how
the self enters the world of
history,
its political activity and
Dante really sort of rejects all
of them.
This prophesy of exile with
which Canto XVII ends gives an
entirely different twist to the
self's relationship to history.
I--inevitably I will belong in
history.
There is no other way,
Dante says, for the self to
exist if not by measuring
oneself with the historical,
the pressures of historical
realities,
but my own relationship to it
is not that--
or that of belonging as Aeneas
does into the world of history
with feeling that I am--
the political world is going to
be my way out of this maze.
It's not going to be the one
like Phaeton and it's not going
to be the one represented by
Hippolytus.
It's the exilic self;
an idea of a self is an art of
dislocation from the world of
history.
But then how are we to
understand this dislocation?
Is dislocation a way of
actually removing oneself
altogether?
Or just saying that I'm out of
place,
just saying that I'm out of
time and somehow I have a
relationship to history which is
maybe polemical,
maybe arguably constructive and
if so what is the way?
I think that we have to reread
now the three cantos in some
detail and we come up with an
answer.
You see then what this--what
the issues here are.
Let me start with Canto XV and
see what Dante is specifically
doing above and beyond this
overall pattern that he's
putting forth in canto-- in the
various cantos.
You will see how in Canto XV
the--let's go back to Canto XV
and you will see that the
relationship to Cacciaguida is
also played etymologically.
How often Dante's punning with
the metaphor of wings;
in Italian it's ali,
Alighieri,
Aligher, that was the name,
the bearers of wings so the--
for instance line 52,
"I speak of thee,
thanks to her who clad thee
with wings for the lofty
flight,"
or a little later on line 70,
"I turned to Beatrice,
and she heard before I spoke
and smiled to me,
a sign that made the wings grow
on my will,"
and later line 80 many,
many times.
He stops after the third time.
"For the reason that is
plain to you,
are not equally feathered in
their wings,"
etc.
The first thing that they do
though with the exchange--
in the encounter with
Cacciaguida is focus on the City
of Florence of old,
an invocation of the golden
age, a certain golden age where
a kind of utopian construction.
These are the lines,
"Florence,"
page--
line--Canto XV lines 94-97 and
following,
"Florence,
within her ancient circle,
from which she still takes
tierce and nones,"
these are the times of the day
rung by the bells of the nearby
church,
"abode in peace,
sober and chased.
She had no bracelet,
no tiara, no embroidered gowns,
no girdle that should be seen
more than the wearer.
Nor yet did the daughter at her
birth put the father in fear,
for age and dowry did not part
from the due measure on the one
side and the other.
She had no houses empty of
family, nor had Sardanapalus yet
come there to show what could be
done in the chamber."
This is a kind of
inferno--evocations,
so these are--you are really
thinking of Cleopatra in Canto
V,
you are thinking of Semiramis,
all these figures of the chaos
of the appetites and they are
being recalled now in this
context "Not yet did your
Uccellatoio"
and so on,
and goes on talking about
Cacciaguida's own birth.
Let me focus a little bit on
this--the metaphors of the--of
Florence.
First of all,
Florence is evoked within a
closed circle of self
sufficiency called "within
her ancient circle."
The circularity of the city
also implies a kind of
plentitude and a sort of
boundary.
Dante does not have an idea of
an expanding city,
just he enjoys the--projects
this idea of a city held within
its own perimeter,
"from which she still
takes tierce and nones,"
the language of space and the
language of time follows,
as if everything could be
measured and everything could be
interrelated.
One is interrelated with the
other.
Then this language of--Florence
is a woman,
sober, chaste,
abode in peace,
sober and chaste,
implying that here at least he
believes and it's lingering in
him the memory of the famous
idea of the so called body
politic that you have heard.
The idea of the organic
structure of the city as made of
interdependent parts just as
space and time indicate the
interdependent coordinates
within which the life of the
city can be recalled.
Now--this is followed in turn
by a sequence of Anaphorus,
all in the negatives,
"she had no bracelet,
no tiara,"
this is the city,
dressed like a woman."
Dante--you know that one way of
thinking about cosmetics is also
to think of it--
they used to think of cosmetics
as bad rhetoric,
perverse forms of seduction by
means of which one could
disfigure the natural continents
and beauty of the human form.
So Dante goes on in a sense by
repeating these negatives,
literally dispossessing,
literally stripping the woman
of all the superfluities,
all these complications and
bring the city back to its own
simplicity,
its original chastity and
simplicity--
let me just see this passage,
"She had no tiara,
no embroidered gowns,
no girdle, not yet did the
daughter at her birth put the
father in fear,
as she had no houses
empty," etc.
This is the golden age.
Does Dante really believe
though in this myth of the
golden age?
This is what we call--there is
a rhetorical phrase for this
sort of move.
Praising the bygone times,
it's the so-called
laudatio,
that means praise of the past,
which is more of a rhetorical
strategy to denounce the
imperfections of today.
In effect, Dante has a
radically polemical view of the
utopian spirit.
This idea of a perfection
that--or the claim of a
perfection that we push back
into the past because it's no
longer with us,
but we want to fantasize about
and nonetheless he is still--
he preserves it because utopia
can become a kind of normative
idea by means of which we can
alter the configuration of our
own contingencies,
our own history.
It may--utopias don't exist,
they may even be dangerous some
people can claim.
A lot of interesting figures in
the history of ideas claim that
utopias are dangerous
constructions because they
ferment illusions about who we
are,
and yet they become for Dante
necessary because we--
in the light of those ideas we
can go on altering what we
perceive as the degradations of
our own times.
Of course this myth of the
golden age of Florence of the
past literally disintegrates
when seen in contrast with the
reality of Dante's life as an
exile which is going to await
him in the future.
That is going to be--so it's
exile as the realistic
perspective of his being in
history.
He makes a virtue of it.
It's not a suffering as we are
going to see,
I'm just--let me just continue
with my thought.
He doesn't see that as a
punishment, it induces
suffering, but it becomes a
virtue and we shall see why it
becomes a virtue.
In effect, it will become a
paradigm in which we can all
recognize ourselves.
In Canto XVI this myth
of--there's also this golden age
of Florence,
there's this illusion that it
abode in peace,
they lived in peace,
whenever I hear the language of
peace I do hear,
I do overhear the echo of
Jerusalem,
the city of peace,
and that's what makes it
interesting,
so it's a typology of another
city,
a golden--the great time,
the golden age of the past is a
kind of--
what the prophets would always
recall as the peace time of
Jerusalem that they had--
that the Jews themselves had
lost and kept on commemorating
in the history.
What makes this conjunction
very strong is that--to me is
that in Canto XVI Dante goes on,
first of all,
talking about this at the
chronicles.
What is a chronicle?
How does the chronicle change
history?
The chronicle reduces--it's a
mode of historiography,
a different mode of
historiography.
The place where you can find
these modalities of history is
really Boethius,
who writes the Consolation
of Philosophy,
at the center of which he
figures the Wheel of Fortune.
You remember the Wheel of
Fortune;
there's this blindfolded woman
who revolves,
who rotates this wheel,
and which means that we who are
always on the shifting curve of
the wheel will be up and down,
so that a kind of
historiography that derives from
this Boethian insight is that of
writing the lives of families
that ascend and descend.
Note, the other mode of
historiography,
should be the historiography of
the fall of empires,
for instance,
Augustine.
So there are two
historiographic models.
The one that you--available in
the City of God,
we are really told about the
fall of the Persian Empire,
the fall of the Roman Empire in
a few pages,
kind of given sort of in a much
more detailed way,
but this is really the idea.
On the other hand,
Dante goes to another
historiographic model which is
that of chronicle.
The idea that history is
reducible to the events,
the local events and
circumstances of one's own life.
He recalls all the families to
the joy of the grandfather who
is--you can understand the
pleasure of memory.
He shuttles back and forth
between,
in memory, between one item and
the other,
recalling everything and Dante
soon discovers that he does not
quite belong,
that that kind of history does
not really account for who he is
and who he wants to be above
all,
and that somehow his definition
of self will depend on a certain
idea of the future and not of
the past.
I am trying to go back to this
idea of who the self is and what
is history, and how are we to
understand history.
Here, to continue with the
notion of Jerusalem,
which I have not--which I
bracketed a little bit and gave
you a little digression on
history,
Dante goes on talking about a
language,
turn to Canto XVI line 50
please where he again talks
about--
it's all about Florence.
"All who were there at the
time between Mars and the
Baptist,"
the mythology of Florence,
cities, not only you recount
stories of families,
you have to recount stories of
the predominant,
the sovereignty of mythologies
that control our own self
understanding.
We tend to understand ourselves
in the light of presiding myths,
of imaginative myths above us,
so there's Mars who's the god
of Florence before the Baptist,
John the Baptist replaced him.
This is the account about the
shifting mythology of the city,
"Mars the Baptist able to
bear arms was a fifth of the
number now living,"
this is really an accounting,
a chronicler's precision and
accounting of Florentine local
history.
"But the citizenship,
which is now mixed with Campi
and Certaldo and Figline,"
and so on.
That language of mixture which
later becomes confusion and
Dante will call it a confusion
when he has to give a diagnosis
at the top of page-- line 67.
Dante has to give a--goes into
a diagnosis of the crisis of the
city,
"The mixture of peoples
was ever the beginning of the
city's ills,
as food in excess is of the
body's."
Once again the connection
between--he's talking about the
malaise of the city by the
connection between body and
cities.
Cities grow and decay and get
sick because of what he calls
the confusion.
First of all he called the
mixture, en confusio,
is the other name for Babylon.
When you have to etymologize
Babylon into the romance
languages and in English,
it's confusion,
so that the two myths of the
city that Dante has in mind is
Jerusalem for Florence and then
Babylon for Florence of today.
The two myths of the cities are
not antithetical;
they are both possible within
the same body politic.
Florence can look like
Jerusalem or it can look like
Babylon according to the way the
moral life of the city is lived
out.
This is something that Dante
will preserve,
but it really implies that the
city,
the political world is one
which one has to shape all the
time,
that you cannot--there is no
definite metaphor or emblem to
define a particular city.
A city can change its very
identity, it can become like--it
can be like a Jerusalem as it
was in the old or it can be like
Babylon now.
The city involves us,
we are involved in the city's
history in the way of making it
according to our own
aspirations, our own ideas;
we share in the shaping and
construction of the city.
This is no longer the
perspective of the chronicler,
it's the perspective of Dante
as the poet;
so it's a critique of the
inadequacy of the chronicle's
view of what history could be.
Now we go back to Canto XVII
where once again and I'm going
to--
I will not go up to our--you
remember it comes to Phaeton and
a rivalry with the father.
Dante's saying if I don't
belong to the city and I--
and city and families go on
decaying and disappearing what
is the true relationship that I
have to this man who is actually
directing me,
and unveiling for me that which
the future--
that which I have to expect
from the future.
These are the kind of questions
that he's very carefully
raising,
so we go back to the famous
description of Dante's exile
where we describe here,
"Thou shalt leave
everything loved most
dearly,"
lines 55,
"loved most dearly,
and this is the shaft which the
bow,
the bow of exile shoots
first."
The condition,
the harshness of exile could
not be crystallized in sharpest
terms.
The severance,
the separation of self from
family as apparently as a
punishment at this point.
"Thou shalt prove how salt
is the taste of another man's
bread."
Those who think that here Dante
is finding a little bit mildly
comical relief in remembering
the fact that in Florence they
do not use salt in their bread,
but anywhere else around we
have a frequent flyer to Italy
who knows very well this little
history,
but I don't think that it's all
that comical.
I think it's the bread,
it's the most sacramental of
foods that he's talking about
and then we shall see how he
picks up the idea of bread in a
moment.
It's just not a metaphor there,
"Thou shall--and how hard
is the way up and down another
man's stairs.
And that which shall weigh
heaviest on thy shoulder is the
wicked and senseless
company."
The word picks up the metaphor
of the bread because company
means,
and that which--it simply means
the sharing of bread with
others,
so bread is truly sacramental
in the sense that it adjoins and
brings about the unity of the
body of the body politic.
What Dante's saying is that
it's a reflection on his own
life, a literal reflection of
his own life.
He went into exile as you know
in the year 1302,
and for a number of years he
went on at least two or three
years,
plotting along the side of his
other fellow exiles the return
to Florence and the destruction
of the enemies who had banished
them.
Really a plot of revenge in
order to restore what they saw
as justice.
Dante very quickly understood
that this was the way to
absolute destruction,
so he just from then on moves
like a shabby derelict.
He represents himself limping
at the beginning of
Inferno and that is
really the way we can--
we are asked by him to imagine
him as he goes when he's talking
about exile.
We are not talking about living
in some kind of isolated
splendor in some court or other.
It literally means going from
place to place begging,
so this is punishment for him,
and yet,
let's see what happens,
"With which thou shalt
fall into that valley which
shall become wholly ungrateful,
quite mad and furious against
thee."
He is an exile to the exiles.
Both the Guelfs and Ghibellines
distrust him and take their
distance from him,
"but before long they,
not thou shall have the brows
red for this.
Of their brutish folly their
doings shall give proof,
so that it shall be to thine
honour to have made a party by
thyself."
What an extraordinary line to
be absolutely on your own,
"a party to thyself."
This should make you--should
give you some perplexity,
to say the least,
because you may remember that
the Divine Comedy begins
with the representation of the
so called neutral angels,
and those neutral angels were
angels who wanted to be neither
with God nor against God,
but they want to be by
themselves.
You remember how I pointed that
out to you, that for Dante this
was the most despicable of
conditions and choices,
though it seems to be
non-choice.
One is really choosing anyway,
even when we are not choosing
we are choosing and he is;
he was separating that to him
it's despicable not to take
sides, to sit on the fence,
and now he seems to attribute
that very condition to himself.
But to you it will be to your
honor to be a party to thyself,
and not only--we did not read
it, but those of you who were so
taken with the poem,
you can go and read Canto VIII
of Paradise,
where Dante will ask one
question he--
to the soul that he meets he
says, is it right for a man in
the city to be a citizen?
Yes, he says,
and I don't even want to ask
why;
it's so clear that has--it
needs no justification,
no explanation,
you have to be part of the--
belong to the world where you
are, and yet now he takes the
other side.
He has to be by himself.
What does it mean to be by
himself?
Is that a kind of neutrality
he's imagining?
Is that--it's really the
condition of exile I think that
he's really describing the
destitution,
the loneliness,
the severance of the self from
others,
but even that can become a
condition that triggers a new
form of relationship.
The exile is still part of the
community and let's see how he
is thinking of this.
I don't want to--this is
his--this is now the specific
prophecy of what's in store for
the exiled.
I think it retrieves,
in this sense I mean that
Dante's bringing about a
transformation of the idea of
exile from what seemed to be a
punishment into a virtue.
There is such a thing as a
virtue of exile.
The language with which Dante
presents the world to come for
him,
the future, this is his future,
it's not the past,
history then is understood as
above all futurity.
We are here oriented to the
future,
the only real time that we
have, we don't have it yet,
but we can--it's the time of
one's projects,
it's the time in which one can
really define oneself.
I'm not really my past so there
is--
I have some contact with the
past, my memories and my
memories can tell you--
me where I'm going but then a
catastrophe occurs.
The need to sever yourself from
anything that you know,
and you love most dearly --
family,
city, loyalties,
your habits,
your bread --
all of these details here are
given and this is what he finds.
"Thy first refuge,
and inn,"
the inn as those of you who
read, it's an interesting
metaphor in the medieval
literature.
Those of you who read Chaucer,
is there anybody here who reads
Chaucer?
The Canterbury Tales,
of course,
it's the story of pilgrims and
the inn becomes the station--
the temporary dwelling of
people who are on the road and
always moving.
It's really one of the most
welcome images in the medieval
imagination, the inn,
the provisional comforts for
the night that the inn offers.
Anyway, "'Thy first refuge
and inn thou shalt find in the
courtesy of the great
Lombard,"
this is the gentleman of
Verona,
the one gentleman of Verona who
houses him and hosted him for a
while,
"who bears on the ladder
the sacred bird,
and he will hold thee in so
gracious regard that,
of doing and asking between you
two,
that shall be first which with
others come after.
With him thou shalt see one who
at his birth so took the impress
of this mighty star that his
deeds will be renowned.
The people have not yet taken
note of him, because of his
youth, for these wheels have
circled about him only nine
years;
but before the Gascon deceives
the noble Henry sparks of his
heroism shall appear in his
disregard both of wealth and
toil,
and his munificence shall yet
be known so that his enemies
cannot keep silence about it.
Look to him and to his benefits.
Through him there shall be
altered fortune for many,
rich changing state with
beggars.
And thou shalt bear this
written in thy mind about him
and shalt not tell it,'--
and he told things which shall
be incredible to those that
witness them.
Then he added:
'Son, these are the glosses on
what was told thee,"
in Inferno XV of course.
Remember when Brunetto says,
"This is the prophecy of
your future exile but it will be
glossed for you by somebody
else."
He doesn't even mention who,
Dante goes on thinking that
it's going to be Beatrice;
it turns out to be his father,
his ancestor.
"These are the snares that
are hid behind a few revolving
years;
yet I would not have thee
envious of thy fellow-citizens,
for thy life shall far outlast
the punishment of the
perfidies.'"
The exile can turn into a
virtue and the language here
that accompanies this prediction
is the language of the ethics of
exile.
That the exile brings about and
needs in order to be bearable
and tolerable,
the hospitality.
These are the great,
the courtesy,
the hospitality,
the language of gratitude,
the giving,
so it's a new ethics is going
to be described in--
from the perspective of this
exilic experience of Dante.
Then Dante concludes,
which I think it seals what I
have been saying,
"'I see well my
father,"
this is line 113 and following,
110 and following,
"'I see well,
my father, how time spurs
towards me to deal me such a
blow as falls most heavily on
him that is most heedless;
it is well, therefore,
that I arm me with
foresight,'"
that's another virtue of exile.
The word translates,
of course, prudence.
Prudence is the human
counterpart of providence.
It's the same etymology,
a seeing in advance,
trying to not predict but
forestall the arrows and flings
that come our way,
"so that if the dearest
place is taken from me,
I may not lose the others by my
songs.
Down through the world of
endless bitterness,
and on the mountain from whose
fair summit the eyes of my Lady
lifted me,
and after, through the heavens
from light to light,
I have learned that which,
if I tell again,
will taste for many of bitter
herbs;
and if I am a timid friend to
truth I fear to lose my life
among those who will call these
times ancient.
' The light within which was
smiling the treasure,"
and then of the reference to
Brunetto who wrote the
Treasure of course.
"I had found there first
became ablaze like a golden
mirror in the sun,
then replied:
'Conscience dark with its own
or another's shame will indeed
feel thy words to be harsh;
but none the less put away
every falsehood and make plain
all thy vision--and then let
them scratch where is the itch.
For if thy voice is grievous at
first taste, it will afterwards
leave vital nourishment when it
is digested.
This cry of thine shall do as
does the wind,
which strikes most on the
highest summits;
and that is no small ground of
honour.
For that reason have been shown
to thee, in these wheels,
on the mountain,
and in the woeful valley,
only souls that are known to
fame;
because the mind of one who
hears will not pause or fix its
faith for an example that has
its roots unknown or hidden or
for other proof that it not
manifest.'"
What he hears,
and the decision that Dante
will take as a palliative at
least, or a remedy to his exile
is writing.
The writing of the poem becomes
the act by which he is an
exilic--
as an exile can go on in his
dislocation,
his utter dislocation from the
city,
from family,
from his habits,
can go on actually relating
himself to a more writing.
The work is the way in which
the self enters history and can
shape history.
It's not Aeneas,
it's not Phaeton,
it's not going to be the
Hippolytus,
it's not even Cacciaguida's own
account of his own grandiloquent
connection with the world of
history,
a way in which Dante's self
enters history is through this
idea of poetry--
of a writing that is now also
described in terms of food,
as you can see here first of
all, with the bitter herbs and
now the voices gives us the
first taste that will afterwards
leave vital nourishment when it
is digested, etc.
Words--first of all,
let me just clear the air here.
No one of you has these
misconceptions about poetic
language that somehow it's some
sort of faint symbol divorced
from reality.
Dante goes beyond this idea of
the relationship of language to
representation.
That was the problem of the
chronicles and they gave fairly
faithful accounts and he can
give fairly faithful accounts.
That's the mode of a certain
historiography.
What Dante's saying is that
words are things in themselves,
that words are food that
change, and being things they
have a kind of solidity and have
a sort of truth value in and of
themselves.
This is really the biblical
language that resurfaces,
son of man, eat the book,
you remember these lines from
Ezekiel?
This is exactly the kind of
language that is returning here,
and which Dante bends,
the sort of language to define
himself in a relationship to his
future project of writing the
poem and that project of writing
the poem is his way of
establishing his place literally
in--
which is a utopian place in
history.
I say utopian because it
doesn't have to be understood in
any local sense.
I do not belong to the city
only because I occupy a
particular place in the city.
It is the act of writing
poetry, that's really what
matters.
What I'm referring to is also,
and here I am,
a sort of correction,
very mild correction of the
classical idea which is also a
medieval--
survives in medieval times the
idea that the self is decided,
the value of the self is
decided by the place one
occupies within the economy of
the city.
Dante says that's not the way
it works.
I am the project of writing my
poetry and through poetry,
which is written in exile,
and therefore it's a poetry of
exile I can re-enter the world
of history.
The world of history accusing
history and talking as a man who
has been touched by the vision
of what justice ought to be,
so this is really the remarks
that I think I can make about
these Cantos XV,
XVI, and XVII and I welcome
questions if you have any.
I'm sure you do.
Yes.
Student:  Would I be
right in seeing some biblical
references within the lines
between 70 and 100,
the mention of the star,
the birth, the inn.
Is that some sort of a Savior?
Prof: This is line 17,
the question is would she be
right in seeing biblical
antecedents,
context for the lines
with--that go from line 70 you
say,
the first refuge and inn.
No, and I "shalt find in
the courtesy of the great
Lombard."
That may be a crystalogical or
a crystal mimetic language
behind these sort of references.
That would be even more--it
would be truer even--
would be made more compelling
in light of Cacciaguida's own
self representation in
crystalogical terms,
both in Canto XV and--in Canto
XVI actually he talks to himself
as if he were a Boethian
philosopher.
Dante uses the same phrase
about the death of Cacciaguida
that he had used for Boethius in
Paradiso XV,
venni dal martiro a questa
pace,
that he had used for Boethius.
But the language is a
crystalogical language.
The only difference is that if
there is any crystalogical
resonance here it very quickly
fades because Dante's really
discussing himself as an exile
with this--
and he understands exile as the
real condition of himself but
also of human beings.
I will go on so far as to say,
in order to connect your
theological perspective and what
I have been saying about the
self in history is that exile is
also the root of one's religious
consciousness.
We have--those of us who have a
religious conscious,
and I think we all do,
just as we have an aesthetic
sense we all do,
that religious conscious comes
always out of the sense or the
feeling even better,
better than the sense,
the feeling that we are not
where we should be.
That we are somehow not where
we should both in terms of time
and in terms of space,
that we are dislocated.
And this exile,
this exilic imagination then
shapes also the theological
language of Dante and accounts
for his persuasion that exile
defines the human condition.
It's not just an empirical--it
is his empirical experience.
That is to say,
it relates to him but he
understands that it's
really--we're all engaged in
this kind of--I'll talk about
this later.
By the way, I'm forcing my hand
because the text does not really
allow me to do that,
but when he discusses hope,
the most extraordinary of all
virtues,
the most deceptive maybe of all
there healing's hope and exile
in a very clear way and I'll
reserve that as a surprise for
whatever next week or--
yeah next week.
Please.
Student:  You mentioned
Augustine's confessions earlier,
and talking about the different
conceptions of how the self
relates to the city,
and you said Dante didn't agree
with Augustine.
I didn't catch everything you
were saying about Augustine's
view of the self.
Can you just review?
Prof: The question is
about--
I was discussing modalities of
this relationship between the
self and history at the
beginning of my remarks.
One of them obviously was--I
mentioned-- let me just give a
little resume of this.
I mentioned Cacciaguida himself
who has a kind of special
understanding of history and
that defines him,
his taking part in the
crusades.
The other one is with which
Dante begins is Aeneas who is a
model for Augustine,
as you know.
I'm answering your question now.
The Confessions of
Augustine are constructed as
nothing less than what we
call--what I call the Aeneid of
the heart.
That is to say,
he goes from Carthage,
he has his Didos;
you remember when he leaves
Carthage to go to Rome,
and the Dido doesn't--he
doesn't just abandon them but he
describes as they hold on to his
garment, etc.
Then he goes to Rome,
so it's really a pattern on an
epic, on the Virgilian epic of
the Aeneid.
But Augustine is very different
from Aeneas.
He doesn't go to Rome to found
an empire.
He's a professor of rhetoric,
he teaches, he's a teacher,
a professor of rhetoric and he
comes to understand himself.
Actually the great moment,
the great revelation for him,
there are two moments of great
revelation to him,
which we really never talked
about.
One, which he's in Ostia,
a little town on the--
by the sea outside of Rome and
he said,
he saw this mother at the
window and they share in a kind
of mystical vision.
He describes this ecstasy that
they have while they look
outside, and then she's about to
die.
That is a decisive moment
in--clearly in his life and his
understanding of himself.
The other one comes in the
Garden in Milan when he hears
voices that tell him to--that he
understands in his own way.
It's an idea of a self which
is--which understands the self
as a death of the old man and
the birth of a new man.
This is the old Adam and the
new Adam.
The Christian idea of
conversion, St.
Paul's command,
you have to let the old man die
so that the new man can come
into being.
That's the understanding of the
self.
Now Dante of course,
when I say he doesn't agree
with it, of course he's not
Aeneas, he did say that.
He's not Paul;
he did say that;
there are those who say well
he's ironic.
I don't see where the irony is.
He's not Aeneas and he's not
Paul;
he uses them to relate,
to coordinate himself to them
and now he's using a number of
other mythical figures.
What is one's own relationship
to genealogy?
to the chronicles?
What is one's own relationship
to mythical empires?
You understand what I'm saying?
The idea of self that he is
going to have is not really
Augustine's;
it's that of the man first of
all who can belong to the
history of the world by writing
the poem.
He lives and he understands the
fundamental quality of the
exilic experience of human
beings, that's not Augustine,
that's really what I meant.
No disrespect for Augustine
only different--a different
experience.
Yes.
Student:  I'm still
thinking about the brief
reference to the crusades that
Cacciaguida makes at the end of
the Canto XV and the presence of
sectarian violence,
and I wonder if that--if Dante
has some idea about that that
connects to his idea of the
empire as staving off the
political violence of civil war
or what would Dante suggest as a
>
because we saw St.
Francis last week who spoke
peacefully with the Sultan of
faith.
Prof: This is an
extraordinary question.
The question is by the way
the--how do I explain
Cacciaguida's reference to the
crusade,
very brief reference to the
and how does that connect with
what we have been talking about
sectarian violence in the Canto
of Dominic for instance in Canto
XII and whether Dante is using
this as a ploy to explain,
just the way he does with the
violence within the city to
justify the necessity of the
Empire,
which he does or is this--or
does he really have an idea of
the peaceful language of
Francis?
Accurate--you asked a lot of
questions and really,
really, really impressive.
After all she's an Italian
major, what do you expect?
She has--she better impress
me--you did, you did.
We'll talk more about Dante's
preparing Canto XVIII,
XIX, and XX is really about--it
starts with what is a heroic
life and how are we to
understand the heroic life.
There's a reference there also
to crusades,
and the question of the
crusades, the relationship of
justice and Christian ideas of
justice to Muslims and Hindus
will come to the forefront
there.
So I really ask you to wait for
that for next time because--
However, I can answer one
question immediately,
which is really implied by what
you are saying more than asked
directly.
Yes, Dante is a peace poet.
I would say that with full
confidence,
though we know Dante was so
polemical,
kicks shades,
is angry, fights,
and there's always competing
visions in relation to the
tradition and others,
but he's--Fundamentally,
you have to establish,
you would say, differences;
not really renounce your
differences,
but actually make those
differences the orchestration,
the musical orchestration that
is going on in Cantos XV,
XVI, and XVII.
This is the heaven of music.
This discordance,
discourses, are part of a
sovereign and transcendent
order,
but he is a peace poet which is
truly scandalous because most
poets,
except for Isaia,
for instance who is a peace
poet--
prophet, a prophet of peace,
with a vision of peace;
Dante really has an irenic
vision.
Most poets write about
victories, about wars,
about armistices,
truces, epic;
the epics in England or in
Italy, it's all about the
clashes of armies,
etc.
Not Dante, so that's really the
direct answer I can give to your
question.
Then you raise another issue
which I find a little bit--I
would not want to go there but I
owe it to you to give an answer.
Well, what about the peaceful
language of Francis?
That seems to be such a great
idea because heresy and schisms
and the question--
the relationship between
Christians and Muslims has
always been one of wars,
so heresy and war,
schism and war,
so we can say that Dante seems
to be so radical in renouncing
war and says,
look it's possible to harmonize
relationship or at least
confront our differences with
using a peace language.
However, things are not as
simple as that and that's why I
only mention it but I will not
go into that.
We haven't got time for that.
It's really a thought I am a
little developing,
I must admit.
The heresy is a question of
language.
It's not just a question of
wars.
So, there are wars that go on
in language and therefore they
re-propose the very differences
and stubborn divisions of
understanding that qualify and
describe both the schisms and
the heresies.
So, to say "peaceful
language,"
it sounds also like another way
of--
another route into potential
descent and tragedy,
you see.
But I am not going to go
anymore than give you as a kind
of suspicion that I have about
my own claim that Dante is a
peace poet.
We'll talk though about the
crusades next time.
And may be I have time for
another question may be and a
very short answer.
Anybody?
See you next time.